sie sehen im hintergrund unserer hübsch
aber das ist aber nur der nationale
anteil des österreichischen bundesheers
das kommando luftunterstützung wir sind
hier heute weder mein satz mit 6
luftfahrzeugen
72 2 agusta bell 212 und 23 wir haben
hier die aufgabe so wie die letzten
sechs tage hier zu unterstützen um das
um das brandgeschehen hier an der
bergflanke die sie danach können
entsprechend zu löschen wir sind hier
haben mit einem multinationalen ewigen
attachment das multinationale
event besteht derzeit aus anteile des
österreichischen bundesheers man ruft
unterstützung aus dem bundesministerium
für inneres aus einem zivilen
hubschrauber aus einem hubschrauber
slowakei und aus zwei löschflugzeugen
kanada aus italien und wir bekommen
jetzt die verstärkung durch die deutsche
bundeswehr mit 2 ch 53 die aus laupheim
kommen und uns hier mit den großen
transporthubschrauber beim löschen
unterstützt